basta con un par de clics y con marcar
una casilla que dice que se tiene la
edad suficiente para acceder a imágenes
pornográficas una práctica común según
estos estudiantes entrevistados
el acceso realmente muy muy fácil No
importa la primera vez que vi porno no
tenía edad suficiente para ver a una
mujer desnuda etcétera etcétera Es
cierto que es impactante y perturbador
si es la primera vez
por ejemplo tú estás navegando y de
repente ves una violación eres joven y
dice Wow los jóvenes analizan pero
ciertamente no es normal se debería
controlar mediante un documento de
identidad quien accede a estos sitios
porno en Francia un estudio reciente
revela que uno de cada dos niños de
primaria y el 100% de los alumnos de
secundaria ya han visto imágenes
pornográficas internet Grifo abierto de
contenidos violentos escenificando a
veces violaciones actos de tortura y
barbarie eso es lo que denuncia un
informe elaborado por cuatro se
hoy en día el referente el disco duro de
Esta generación es la pornografía con
una imagen de la mujer degradada de
maltrato de violencia sexual
por lo tanto se debe invertir la lógica
y es necesario demostrar que la
pornografía la industria de la
pornografía no se basa en la realidad de
las relaciones sexuales no es la
realidad de las relaciones con mujeres
dos plataformas francesas están siendo
investigadas por la justicia por
complicidad en violaciones y tráfico de
personas para proteger a los menores el
informe recomienda bloquear los sitios
pornográficos que no apliquen verdaderas
restricciones de edad y ampliar el
control de los padres